hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of old vs.
[Applause]
[Music]
who would have thought a story about a
giant monkey who falls in love with a
woman climbs buildings and smashes
dinosaurs would be considered a classic
well King Kong certainly once when it
was released in 1933 it captured the
world's interest with its groundbreaking
effects and a timeless story about what
happens when two threatening majors
collide since then there's been several
remakes but they sucked donkeys and none
of them have been considered on par with
the original then it is until 2005 when
Peter Jackson took his shot at telling
the story this is the only version that
people say is not only as good as the
original but possibly better but can it
truly outdo the classic is there really
enough there to keep it fresh and new
while still staying true to the original
well let's find out I never thought I'd
be put in a position to say this but
it's monkey versus monkey here on this
dowser crate this is old versus new King
Kong
[Music]
well we can't tell this beauty in the B
story without our beauty that is not the
beauty for most of us I'm talking about
our main actress who happens to play the
main actress this is our best leading
lady
not both of these films have good
charismatic actresses each has to have a
charming personality and good looks to
match in order to tame the beast
they are certainly different though in
the original the character of Darrow is
played by favoring who is constantly
told that she doesn't belong I'm bored I
wish he wouldn't keep harping on that
it's very mean of you women women just
can't he'll be in a bother
made that way again despite that though
she still keeps an optimistic point of
view don't you think the skipper this
wheedle man I need to have him here meet
David in the newer version she's played
by Naomi Watts who's a little more
welcomed on the ship so she doesn't have
to defend herself as much lovely dress
oh this whole thing I just threw it on
both have to play the classic screaming
damsel in distress and in terms of
traditional screamers babe ray is
probably a little closer but once
portrayal has a little bit more edge to
it in the original King Kong just sort
of lights down and even though they make
her very positive and energetic all she
does around calling you scream Branton
we don't want to see anything bad
happened to her but she doesn't do
anything that would make Kong really
like her the number one has to work for
her survive they indicated that Kong has
killed dozens of sacrifices in the past
but because of her performance training
she's able to actually entertain Kong
but even she has her limits that's all
there is
she's standing up to a 10-story gorilla
that takes balls
or ovaries I don't know but he takes a
lot of them because of this the newer
version truly does have a better lead
she's just more interesting and takes
more chances the original is good too
you really do like her and don't want to
see her in danger but the screaming just
gets a little old after a while
[Music]
yeah scream somewhere maybe he'll
finally go away
plate goes to the new oh dear and I
thought everything was going so nicely
[Music]
but what about the supporting cast do
they match up just as well as the lead
well here's the little people that
literally got stepped on to make it to
the top
let's start with the romantic leap in
the original he's played by Bruce
Kennedy a rough and gruff sailor who
doesn't like the idea of women being
aboard his ship now why would that be
[Music]
no that's not it in fact he actually
ends up falling in love with Darrow
even if it is pretty sporadic we have
anything could happen to you
well then you wouldn't be bothered with
heavier woman on the board hey I guess I
love you I've only known you for five
minutes but Don what's a giant gorilla
comes through the trees and steals you
away I think you're the one and granted
some of the dialogue is a little hokey
too in fact they even make fun of it in
the remake the lines they shoot for
their movie are actually identical to
the ones they say me original except in
the original now supposed to be the real
dialogue I think it's a go pretty
exciting I've never been on a ship
before well I've never been on one with
a woman before I've never been on one
with a woman before but for all the
stereotypical Macho nests he actually is
pretty likable sort of a tough guy with
a soft heart sort of thing well I guess
we weren't the only one in the new one
we get Adrien Brody who way straight up
boring those pure excellence I filled up
the band try to resist that impulse I'm
sorry but he's just not interesting I
know they're trying to downplay the hero
aspect and make him look like a normal
boring guy but you can still make him
look like an interesting boring guy if
that makes any sense
why would I write a play for you
but God your doll what about the crazy
director that takes him on this voyage
again I prefer the original played by
Robert Armstrong mostly because if you
looked at him you wouldn't guess like he
was an eccentric thrill seeker he's very
professional and sort of keeps to
himself which shrouds his character in a
lot more mystery but you've got a
reputation for recklessness that can't
be glossed over and then you're so
secretive good lord you talk as if I
never brought anybody back alive when
you see him you think sort of a mad
genius a guy who can convince you to
jump off a cliff if it would make the
shot look good why do I have to do just
trust me and keep your chin up he's very
smooth even if he is batshit insane jet
black on the other hand is a little too
obvious he only says his eyes bugging
out and oh he seems to talk in an
intensive manner no call you can't do
telling the studio pressured us into an
early departs it's not gonna do sue me
huh now granted a lot of directors do
act like I'm doing a gimmick now how
kind of us I'm doing average man more
intensity sent a time before avoids this
crazy you have to have the ability to
convince people and make them trust you
and I don't get that from black I don't
believe anyone would go with him on a
crazy voyage I don't know maybe I just
can't trust anyone who isn't biodome
that would take anybody's liability for
me the rest of the crew in the new
version though are pretty memorable
I like Andy Serkis is cut for a cook
cost why you spoke of a creature but at
least oh man yeah anyway and I felt that
Hays guy was pretty mysterious to the
rest of the crew the original is pretty
forgettable you know outside of the
obvious racial stereotypes may not see
one two hours it'll turn me fine on
thick make it breakfast crazy black man
been here speaking of which that tribe
is pretty silly-looking nowadays isn't
it I'm sure it's impressive back then
but now it just looks silly you've come
across more realistic natives in
Gilligan's Island the ones in the newer
version are just fucking crazy and a lot
more intimate
look chocolate like chocolate
notice of chocolate Means War
sort of a toss-up but I am going to go
with the original mostly because of the
romantic lead in the film director
they're just bigger roles so they still
come a lot more credit and in this
comparison that adds up to a lot point
goes to the old what are you an idiot
[Music]
and now we come to the effects Jean shut
up you no no it's gonna be the new
version I mean remember the effects back
then with the original work
groundbreaking new version
now I know what you're thinking how can
the effects of the original be anything
compared to the new well to be honest
these are still very impressive effects
for that time and not only that they had
to get really creative to make them
happen obviously King Kong a stop-motion
but for the people sometimes they had to
take still pictures and would animate
them along with Kong other times they
would use a green screen other times it
was force perspective other times they
would literally just build a giant Kong
that's a lot of creativity and a lot of
hard work the newer one is mostly
computers I mean everything is computers
nowadays and don't get me wrong that
doesn't mean it's not a lot of hard work
put into it but it just gets a little
tiring seeing CG effects over and over
and over and to be honest they're not
that spectacular when I think of good CG
effects I think of something that either
looks realistic like Gollum or the
Headless Horseman or something stylized
like Sin City or across the universe
here I can always tell it's computers
sometimes there's models but it's mostly
computers but let's be honest yeah it
does look a lot more realistic granted
I've never really thought the creatures
were there in the new one but then again
I really never thought they were there
in the original I guess that's not
really the idea of either film though
we're not there to admire the effects
the effects are going to help the story
we don't have to believe the characters
are really there we just had to feel
what they're going through and both
films do a very good job of that but it
is our mommies who the winner is isn't
it the newer version though I still
really admire the original for its
creativity and in my opinion there's
still pretty damn impressive fine goes
to the new well there's a good reason
[Music]
and now we come down to the eighth
wonder of the world himself which one
had the better call which one did you
feel more sorry for and which one had
more heart and soul I don't know but I
don't think either of them could compare
to a me nobody was more compassionate
and heartfelt than her
now for me this is the hardest part
because I really like both corns and
again you think it's an effects thing
but it's really not it's just that
they're both really well portrayed they
both have a big heart and both fall in
love with our main lead there are
definitely some major differences in the
original Kong is much more animalistic
the way he moves in the way he acts is
much more like an actual ape
okay the movements aren't quite as
realistic but the actions are look at
the scene where he's trying to get this
guy you can see the wheels in his head
are tourney's he's trying to figure out
how the map
[Music]
this one also has a very blank
expression you can't always tell when
he's happy or sad oh yeah much like a
real animal in fact the way a lot of
these creatures move seems very
animalistic again it's not totally
realistic but you sense the survival
techniques these creatures have they
react like predators who will stop at
nothing until they stop their prey
because of this there are a lot more
threatening and a lot more unpredictable
the remake is a little different
they actually model Kong after a real
actor Andy Serkis so you can very easily
tell what emotion he's feeling at the
time for no dialogue they get across a
lot with this character and you really
get the idea about what he's going
through whenever he's on screen in a
sense they sort of develop him a little
bit more and make him a little bit more
humanistic the only downside is that
it's not very animal-like not that
animals don't feel anything I know they
do but they're creatures of instinct
first plus when you look at an animal
it's very hard to figure out what
they're feeling or thinking that's why
so many of them are unpredictable
because of this it's the blank
expressions of the original Kong but I
surprisingly have more emotion for he
just seems much more like a creature now
stolen from his natural environment I
guess it's because we don't know what
he's thinking and he's probably not
super smart that we feel even more sorry
for look at that naive dumbass smile I
feel so sorry for that Jim even before
the bad things happen to them and again
the new one is very good but it seems a
little bit more like a performance than
an actual animal it moves more like an
animal but doesn't act as much as an
animal and even though I feel sorry for
him I feel more sorry for the original
he just seems more helpless to me inside
and at the end you're always gonna feel
more sorry for the more helpless
creature one goes to the old what you'll
bolshevik or something
you
[Music]
once again the beat deciding point is
story which one told the tale of he
meets girl back
this is best story
both of these films have very similar
stories but the newer ones seems to go
into a lot more detail in original
everything is sort of a which I guess is
the idea right surrounding everything
about the adventure in mystery and the
new one though we get a lot more
background we see the deciding point for
when the director goes to the island
you see pharaoh's job before she tags
along with him and we spend quite a bit
of time on the boat before we even get
to the giant davis too long i became so
fucking sick of this boat of these damn
people on it i know what they're trying
to do they're trying to hold themselves
to that role of Jaws where you wait an
hour to show the monster but this is way
too fucking long and they have the
people on the ship aren't that
interesting anyway so you're just kind
of stopped there I mean who's gonna
entertain me Adrien Brody look I looked
in the pianist but you are boring
the original was much quicker into the
point there was certainly build-up but
not to the point where it got annoying
and tedious
hello ever in a new one we do get a
better connection between Darrow and
Klaus there's actually quite a few
silent moments where you really see them
make sort of a strange connection
together in the original it's a bit more
tribal it's a little bit more harsh and
cold the newer one seems to have a lot
more heart than the original but even
that seems to go a little too far like
when she visits him in the city okay I
know she's trying to tame him and keep
him under control but then they go ice
skating that's just weird how can I take
this seriously it's calling on ice I
keep expecting Mickey Mouse to pop up at
any moment
plus there's just some all-around
strange seams in the new one like how
about when the director tells the writer
exactly where they're going this is one
of the oddest things ever it's totally
over the top for no reason it has a
local name but the warning of Jack it
doesn't sound good
so yeah there's quite a few over-the-top
scenes like that but to be fair there's
a lot of over-the-top scenes in the
original - but here's the difference the
original was made in the 30s at a time
when this was not considered that corny
this was made just a few years ago and
the corny scenes were corny even then
like how about that guy who falls in
slow-mo where everyone else moves
regularly why was his fall such a big
deal was he's the directors brother or
something how about some of those quirky
over-the-top performances Mr Driscoll if
you don't mind me saying but you don't
look at all like your photograph you see
I I was just afraid that you might be
one of those self-obsessed literary
types you know the Tweety twerp with his
nose in this book and its head up is
that well how about that
cutting frame straight that's never been
fucking cool little stuff like that
really adds up in the long run and even
though there's a lot of really good
things about the newer version the
original just tells the story better
there's no tricks no avant-garde or
artsy way of showing things it's just
the straightforward story so when
everything is added up it really does
seem like that the original King Kong is
the superior film
plecos to do a better movie
[Music]
so that's my old versus new on King Kong
stay tuned next week when I go view drop
dead friend that's a movie so bad will
make you flip Bobby your skull Oh I said
skull nostalgia remember it's a crazy
black man been here